yo what's up fellas um got the uh i got
the bike in the back for the thick boys
club
uh but quick king intersting it for you
uh being 28 years old and moving into a
nursing home
um got some money saved out my
grandmother lives in a nursing home
the amenities are really nice so i'm
thinking about
taking the plunge let me know what you
guys think
living in a nursing home is someone in
his 20s
gang gang orangutang well here's the
thing about when all your [ __ ]
roommates are 99
listen you can get real close with sally
she passes away
yeah think about that so you're
constantly dealing with death
all the time i think khan's i hear the
same stories all the time
you know what i'm saying theo huh a nice
bedtime story is fun
every night though every night becky
every night
bro i i think first of all you'd have no
fomo anymore
because everybody's if you step to 7 15
you're the freaking
pit bull of this whole entire
environment dude like you're the
you're the rick james if you stay up to
7 30 you're rick james's place
yes bro you were a legend people like
what happened last night
you know all right so if you want to be
the coolest guy at the old folks home
do that bubba but also think about this
think about low-key
the life insurance policies you're going
to get in on okay you show up to court
dude and the
kids are like who in the [ __ ] is that
and you're like i'm your grandfather's
bridge partner
i'm your grandfather's best friend
[ __ ] i've known him for two
weeks and he left everything to me
that's who i
am hands down bro sometimes showing up
at the finish line is where you got to
show up
and then also dude you're going to get
there's a lot of
scx that goes on at these places there
is some wrinkly sex
and so you're going to get opportunities
and you're going to get
yeah is there sex in nursing homes what
does it say next 40 percent it happens a
lot
about 40 uh of people between that age
but yeah i've seen this i'm looking for
the studies that show it's
it's rampant yeah if you're interested
in an old uber driver yeah
i was an uber driver she was old well
either way
nick sorry nick molesta your passenger
yeah
i mean again if you want to be the
[ __ ] you know
the baller of the old folks home and
[ __ ] the old ladies
fire away my man i don't think there's a
lot of competition
i'm not talking about taking advantage
of them i'm talking about enjoying
somebody's company
and giving somebody a little bit of love
in their life before they go to heaven
dude
and also you get to do all the games
dude board games arts and crafts bingo
stuff i love jell-o have you had jello
recently yeah i have sugar-free jello
i dude about two months ago i ordered so
much jello to my house dude
and i've been loving it it's great oh
you've got so great and
the other thing you're forgetting about
now i'm kind of sold on it unlimited
graham crackers
vanilla wafers dude imagine just showing
up you
roll out of bed at 4 45 a.m
that's the tough part you got to get up
early get up early but there's no sleep
in there yeah
you roll out of bed there's a hearing
downstairs because your buddy uh
gertrude died right yeah so you go down
there
his kids show up you roll off twenty
percent richer after an inheritance fair
point
into a lunch that has ice cream yes
checkers all out you want to wipe your
ass whatever you want
those rails while you [ __ ] yeah or while
you're taking a bath
now you can't bring any hoes back to the
old folks home so you gotta
you're gonna have to pay your dues you
don't think you can no
you can have visitors no you can't bring
some young thot up in that [ __ ]
maybe not during coffee times but you
definitely can man common assisted
living amenities
linen service sign me up unlimited linen
you know expensive
medication management give me all the
pills i want
uh in the latino community do they have
do a lot of uh grandparents go into
senior
care or no no i've never heard of them
like your family is just
family and you know till the end they
still there yeah
yeah but it's kind of nice though right
yeah yeah it's pretty nice yeah you get
to spend their last moments with them
it's a beautiful thing
that's the problem with american culture
is we just ship off our seniors
they ship them off into like just uh
well because white people
our parents get on our nerves so you
kick them without as soon as you turn 16
you're all [ __ ] see a peter and
debbie
yeah there's no sense of like uh yeah it
gets a little bit like you want your own
space yeah and rightfully so
yeah maybe but um what else you got nick
i say king it man i'm for it and i think
stuff like this is going to start to
happen more i think you're going to see
people want to have a more community
style of living
here's the problem though you bet you
better keep it high and tight man
because you bring coconut in that [ __ ]
everybody dying you know what i'm saying
so you got to wear a mask at all times
if you're going out playing with
basketball with your buddies
you come back we gotta get you cover
tested cause one covet positive and that
old folks home everybody dying like
[ __ ] dominoes
yeah there goes your whole crew there
goes your best friend i should decide to
grab
tacos at tiny tacos especially they're
[ __ ]
yeah they're breathing each other i
don't know if they're sexually
transmitted cove it is there
not but they breathe in children no you
can have sex with a mask on
yeah um okay i'll king it if he wants to
do it i'll king it
okay a lot of positives now that we
talked through it
yeah dude imagine right now you roll out
of here you go back there
there's people downstairs always to play
with to hang out with always to read
always someone to drop knowledge on you
talked about jim crow laws
yeah talk to you about the wars yeah
civil war charlie chaplin oh yeah
charles manson jfk the notebook watching
the notebook over and over again
and everybody claiming it's their story
yeah should be dope man
i told you you said no i'm into it now
though yeah
is